Society is becoming less masculine over
time right men's testosterone is going
down women are much more vocal and
present in public life now obviously we
don't approve of that but you know sorry
but you know what I mean right society's
becoming more feminized and you you can
think that's a good thing or you can
think that's a bad thing or you can be
neutral about it but it is happening
would you agree
I do worry about men and and I don't
spend a lot of time on that but yes yeah
and some of the this values that drive
some of these social movements they are
quite obviously stereotypically more
feminine than they are masculine when
because they're based on things like
empathy and compassion and you know all
of that taken to an extreme where they
become quite damaging actually
um and I just wonder whether to some
extent the fact that we so prize
compassion and empathy to to an extreme
that's dangerous is maybe a product of
the fact that Society is readjusting to
a new dynamic between men and women
um and you I mean you said it yourself
it's mothers that that often behave in
this way right
um are there just too many women around
yeah
have they got too much power I mean do
you see what I'm saying or am I being I
do I it's really difficult as a woman
knowing uh how I um go about this world
and being a specific sort of woman
um amazing
um but it's very it's very difficult to
then talk about
the impact on men I think I think a big
danger factor for men is porn I think
that's a big danger thing for society in
general uh let me just get that out of
the way
um
I think it's very difficult to talk
about male violence
and accept that most men are not going
to beat you up in your own home right
most men are not going to rape you on a
night out if they can
um and so these themes that we talk
about it's a minority of men
um
I've got three sons
I want my sons to be men and I've got a
A very wise person I know is a man
called Brian
and he talks about masculinity is your
sword in your sheath it's having all the
power
knowing that you can use it but not
having to but it being very very
super aware to everybody that you've got
it
um
that's the masculinity that I'm really
attracted to
um I'll have a door open for me actually
every day of the week yeah and heavy
things carried because I'm five foot one
I offered to carry a bag
it wasn't that heavy though that's why I
offered
um exactly sure
um but
I do worry I don't know if I think that
this particular theme is all about
men being emasculated because I think
it's it's the height of I don't even
like toxic masculinity I think it's
mostly bull
but I do feel there is an element of
real toxic kind of at the peak of
masculinity is then like the ultimate
woman-hating thing you could do is
pretend that you are one yeah I'm just
I'm concerned
I'm a I'm somebody that doesn't cry very
much right I'm relatively stoic some
some horrible things have happened to me
in my life and I'm it doesn't break me
at all
I think I've mentioned this before if I
had a husband that broke under I
wouldn't like that or not but then I'm
not going to break no well I I get what
I'm getting at is
um it's a difficult one to discuss and
it's difficult for you because you're a
woman's rights campaigner that's your
focus I I guess what I'm saying is and
again Jordan Peterson mentioned this is
if you think strong men are dangerous
just wait until you see weak men oh I
agree with you you know I just don't
know what a strong man it's very it's
it's a it's a difficult thing to
describe
what does a strong man look like I think
a strong man takes his responsibility to
the father very seriously yes
um I think a strong man wants to protect
the mother of his children as well as
his children right and then my role is
to protect my children and maybe look
after my husband my role as a wife is to
serve him and his role as a husband is
to serve me and that will of course make
a difference in the way that we do that
because I had babies my role my
reproductive role is to have the babies
I can't possibly think that something so
important wouldn't have an impact on the
rest of my personality and life and I
mean even childless women I think we
have um
instinct which I like used to call like
Legacy memory which is we we bring the
experience of our ancestors not in a
kind of like come by our spiritual way
but just I believe that if you can have
Instinct that is informed in your genes
and you know how to do it then why
wouldn't you carry anything else from
previous
Generations why wouldn't it be sort of
in your blood and your bones
so
I I do get you and I
I think you're right I just I just
wonder if some of the things that we had
to change for women to be considered
equal because our society is set up on
the structure of success and finance
so in order to have autonomy you have to
have money
but in order to have a baby you have to
rely on as a woman you have to rely on
somebody to provide that money
and I've got women who like I wouldn't
uh like rely on my husband I was like
well the state then is that different is
the state not the patriarchy if you're
saying that your husband is I mean I'm
all up for relying on my husband for
cash
it suits me fine but so we had to
we had to get through some of the things
that genuinely did subjugate women yes
we had to get through it and we found
these particular Solutions and they're
not perfect by any stretch and maybe
this is the consequences yeah well this
is what this is what I'm getting at
right because the the progress inverted
commas that we've made over the last 60
years there's been some good things
about that but like when you start
pulling on the sweater you don't know
which lines are going to come out of it
and it just seems to me that what you're
talking about there's is considered
trans nowadays which is the idea that a
man and woman get together and have
children and look after each other in
different ways
um and you know Louise Pera I don't know
if you've you're familiar with her I am
she wrote a lovely article about me in
The Spectator yeah is that sarcasm no no
no yeah it was really nice yeah and her
book is is very good and I think her
book is basically making this point it's
like the sexual revolution had its
benefits but look at this not great
though
I mean I don't
I don't know too many women who have a
good time on a in a short relationship
quite yeah quite but that is now the
standard for young women
yeah I mean they're just they've been
both men and women have been coerced
into thinking that there is fulfillment
in
um numbers by the way you know what a
lot of women don't understand if I think
is that it's not good for men either no
it's really not it's really not it
doesn't make men happy there's there's a
small minority of men who who are happy
with it for a while and then eventually
they have kids and settle down with with
somebody but for most men it's not good
either